it's what President Donald Trump calls a
science-based plan to get the United
States back on its feet he's issued
guidelines in three phases that advise
each state when they can begin to reopen
and what doctors say will be a new
normal
America wants to be open and Americans
want to be open as I have said for some
time now a national shutdown is not a
sustainable long term solution to
preserve the health of our citizens we
must also preserve the health and
functioning of our economy over the long
haul
the first phase calls for social
distancing and for schools and
businesses to remain closed but some
larger venues including restaurants and
movie theaters could reopen if states
see a steady decline in coronavirus
cases they can move to Phase two in
which schools some businesses including
bars could open but gatherings remain
limited the third phase will allow
workers to go back to their jobs and for
at-risk people to continue to take
precautions we took the greatest economy
in the history of the world and we
closed it in order to win this war and
we're in the process of winning it now
our approach outlines three phases in
restoring our economic life we are not
opening all at once but one careful step
at a time
Democratic Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi called the plan vagin
inconsistent citing concerns over the
need for rapid testing the corona virus
has taken a harsh toll on the u.s. more
than 30,000 people have died and there
have been over 600,000 confirmed cases
22 million people are now out of work
wiping out a decade of job growth
President Trump says the US will be back
and greater than ever but this is a
delicate process that comes down to a
state-by-state county-by-county basis
some states may enter phase 1 as early
as Friday others face a far longer slog
business leaders governors and
scientists warn a shortfall in testing
could hamper efforts
to reopen the country that decision now
lies with each state's governor in some
states coronavirus cases are yet to peak
and as a risk of the virus making a
comeback in the months ahead
personal protection equipment for health
workers is still in short supply but
even if you are in phase 1 2 3 it's not
ok game over it's not it's gonna be a
way that we protect ourselves because as
we know and as I've said from this
podium it may very well be as we go the
cycle around that there'll be this virus
that wants to come back to us I think
we're gonna be able to handle it this is
a cautious approach to reopen the
world's largest economy something
president Trump has long wanted to do
the challenges for each state a huge the
dangers of making the wrong decision now
crucial and is yet there's still no
vaccine and a Gallacher al Jazeera